seen in the last few minutes various
flashbangs administered by the French
riot police to try to disperse the crowd
if you like
the senses that uh
really I think amongst a lot of the
people here this they're almost at the
Last Chance Saloon if you like in terms
of being able to get their voice heard
if you look over to the sort of central
uh point over here you can see a lot of
people Gathering
hooded
just looking into the crowd now to sort
of see what what's going on
um
you know the anger here really is
amongst people who feel that they have
to get their voice heard today and they
have to get their voice heard because
tomorrow there is going to be this uh
decision by the Constitutional Council
which is essentially going to decide
whether or not the French government has
acted within the boundaries of the
French Constitution by raising this
pension age from 62 to 64. now that's
almost like the kind of the last legal
position in terms of that's the end of
the road in terms of challenges but
still there will be this residual anger
against the French President Emmanuel
macron because of the way that it's
being done by the French government the
sense that they tried to achieve it
through the back door because it doesn't
because he hasn't got an absolute
majority in Parliament to push through
this controversial legislation so
um people here are gathering essentially
over recent months there have been some
tens of thousands the numbers some
people suggest around the hundred
thousand Market previous protests which
have been going on now on a weekly basis
since last January so for 12 weeks now
this is the 12th solid day of protests
over that three-month period And it
involves uh Striker strikes for various
unions for the involving transport
education bins that have been on fire
this capital is crippled uh and it gets
crippled on a weekly basis
um people not going to work crippled
within schools bins on fire let me just
try and take you over here and give you
a sense of how people are kind of lining
up against the riot police a new front
line by this place de la Bastille and as
I said before this sort of sense that
this is the kind of crunch moment there
you go they're moving in now to try and
[Music]
foreign
who are
trying to take on
the French authorities the French police
themselves throwing any kind of
incendiary devices that they perhaps may
be able to get their hands on
the French ripe is moving forward then
pushing back this kind of cat and mouse
this kind of push and pull between the
two sides on the one hand here the
French Riot police and then over here
towards this place de la Bastille uh a
lot of the so-called agitators there's a
kind of romp hardcore rump who are
particularly disenchanted not only
because of these pension reforms but the
fact that they see this almost as as an
assault on French democracy lies at the
very heart of a liberty egality the fact
that the French president has tried to
do this outside of parliament so there's
a lot at stake here and it's kind of
quite hard to see how this is going to
be dissolved uh overnight even if there
is this kind of ruling tomorrow by this
constitutional Council let me take you
over there again you can see the rightly
smoothing
[Music]
moving
so what they're doing is kind of moving
into certain Pockets at a time when
there are these mini clashes on the one
side the protesters who are out to make
their voice heard laced with violence it
has to be said and on the other you know
I've been talking earlier to a 78 year
old man who was here saying like I had
to come down
I'm okay I'm 78 years old pension
reforms won't affect me but I'm here for
the next Generation so we've been
talking to school teachers I was talking
to a young beautician earlier who was 33
years old and saying look it makes a
huge difference this is a line in the
sand moment for France
uh
you can see people moving back this way
so what's happening of course you got
this as I say this kind of cat and mouse
on the one side the protesters who will
be throwing off fireworks uh possibly
tear gas as well to try to disperse
[Music]
oh he's still on
yeah
this this disenchantment it's this real
disenchantment
um amongst this uh younger elements of
society who who just say
we we will not accept this we will not
tolerate this and you know it is very
hard to see how these protests which uh
have got stronger and stronger although
some people say that they've got a bit
weaker over recent weeks it's hard to
see how they are going to just simply
disappear even if this ruling tomorrow
does go in the favor of the French
government and goes against the voice of
the people here tear gas is being used
we've certainly seen it in the side
streets throughout the course of the
afternoon
we're being pulled back here
I'm just going to get my
uh
respirator out